oh hello yes I can see you so it's gonna
be a bit obvious already boat Steve
you'll apart from the fact that you're
frozen and turned into a load of garbled
mass suggesting I might need to turn the
video off what are we talking about
today it's a bit of a different type of
day as you can see I'm not at the
University I am working from home like
most people in the world so we're going
to record a computer file Sean is at
home with his house were socially
distancing I'm at my house I've got my
camera out I'm sitting in my dining room
and we're going to talk about working
from home one of the things that I've
been doing over the last weeks I've been
using software like Microsoft teams to
communicate with my students and things
everything now lead rescue of nothing
was being done online and I thought it'd
be interesting to spend a few computer
files talking about the technology that
people are using to work from home we'll
do a series of videos on these sort of
things while we're all locked down and
we'll explore something sort of overview
and others will go down into details or
some of the nitty-gritty stuff and I
thought the first one to start with
would be to look at what people are
using to connect to their work networks
which in is Virtual Private Networks
there's two uses of VPNs there's a sort
of use of people use it at home perhaps
and there's a sort of use that people
use in the business world where they're
trying to connect to their corporate
network so they can use resources that
exist on that corporate network and it's
that latter view that I'm going to talk
about today the technology use are doing
both from when using at home to sort of
protect your traffic if you're on a
hostile network and when you're the
business world is the same but the
emphasis is slightly different we're
going to talk about it from the business
world emphasis because of the current
situations I think the place to start is
to think about how people use their
computers and networks in a business and
then we can extrapolate from that the
problem that we need to solve with a
virtual private network and then how the
technology works from that so going to
draw a little diagram I don't have any
computer listing paper here but I have
the next best thing
I have my iPad with computer listing
paper all right and we'll draw on that
and hopefully the screen capture worth
anybody else to see what
doing let's have a think about what a
typical corporate network would be we
would have some computers that people
will use and these would sort of been
networked together let's just have a
couple it would be a small office and
they're all connected to a single
network and alongside that there might
be servers that you use so there might
be for example a file server which
contains some secret information we'll
call this the files and we might have a
database which has got some information
off and on a normal corporate network
you can access that quite easily the
machines can send packets out over the
network to the fast server and access
and things are generally secure you may
have some permission set up so only the
right people can access the right
services and so on but these days that
network is going to be connected via
some sort of router to the internet and
if I can draw a cloud picture that will
be the internet after those machines can
also access the internet via the router
and the Richer can act as a firewall so
that people can't get into it from the
outside and that all works absolutely
fine the problem comes us if we have a
person sitting out in a cafe or working
from home asan who wants to access those
same resources we need to provide access
to those resources without making them
insecure now some of these you could
secure and put directly out on the web
there's no problem doing that but some
of them may be devices that you don't
want that accessible out on the wide
internet what we want to be able to do
is to have the person who's sitting here
on the outside be able to access as if
they were directly connected to that
Network but of course they're not in the
physical premises so we can't just run a
cable to them so how do we get around
this well what you could do at one point
is you could buy a good educated
connection from your telecoms company
and they would run a wire from your
business premises to say the person's
home and you could connect them directly
whether you have a direct cable that ran
across the whole thing the other thing
you could do is use a dial-up modem when
the person would ring over the telephone
network and connect with that way you'd
have remote access by that but that
requires specific resources requires a
dial-up modem of either diet can
actually be
into plus what would be great is if
someone could just sit on the internet
and access those resources from wherever
they are but with the same level of
access as if they had a physical
connection to the network and this is
what a virtual private network is trying
to solve now how does that work well we
need to think about how the computer is
actually communicating over the local
network and then we can extrapolate out
from that to see how the data gets sent
over a virtual private network so let me
bring up a new sheet of virtual paper
this is an interesting experience doing
a computer file this way it's very
different from doing a Bashan in the
room so let's think about it we've got a
machine on the local network and we've
got a file server so it's trying to
access files through that now in a way
that modern networks work particularly
IP networks we take the data we're
trying to send and we break it down into
a series of chunks which we call copies
and we send a series of chunks out over
the network
but those chunks don't go as pure data
over the network we need to sort of wrap
them up so that when they get to the
other end they can be sort of unwrapped
and put back together in the right order
because depending on how that was
configured depending on how complicated
the network is they may get to take
different routes to get to the point so
there's various things generally would
have the data in a package and then on
top of that we put a series of headers
that tell us things so on a standard
Network these days you'd have a TCP
header there that would tell it with the
order than these packets need to go in
and then you'd have an IP header put in
front of that which would tell it where
it's going where it's come from and then
these days the local network or the one
would certainly be Ethernet and that
whole lot will be put inside an Ethernet
packet and so we'll have an Ethernet
header at the top and then that could be
sent either directly to the machine that
once there or to a machine they can pass
it on to the machine that wants it over
the company's local network so that's
how we send data over the local network
but we can actually do the same thing if
we had a direct connection rather than
having the Machine put it directly on
the local network we'd have another
machine which was connected to the local
network and connected to the direct kin
action and it would give an IP address
to the remote machine remember this is a
physical direct connection either via
dial-up modem link or a physical leased
line from the telecoms company and then
it wouldn't put the ethernet header on
the front of that there so these in that
header would disappear but it would wrap
it up in some other form of hello so the
usual one that was used on leased lines
was a PPP a point-to-point protocol
packet header same thing we take the
data wrap it up in the TCP header wrap
it up into an IP header and then send it
out using PPP over the direct connection
between the two machines so that's how
we could do it there but what if we want
to do this with someone who's just
sitting on the Internet what we can do
basically a very similar thing we give
the remote machine an IP address as if
it was on our network but rather than
sending that packet directly to the
machines over the Internet what it does
it takes that wrapped up IP package and
it wraps the whole lot up as another
packet so it has a UDP header here
that's another way things communicate
over the Internet and there's a reason
why it uses UDP over TCP which we might
cover in a later video and then that
gets wrapped up as another IP packet but
this time rather than saying waves were
to go on the local network this is going
from the remote machines address on the
Internet to a gateway server on the
running at the company so that then gets
sent over the Internet to the right
machine to the gateway server and then
the header can be removed the UDP header
to leave the original IP packet that was
sent by the machine and the same thing
can happen in Reverse but there's a
couple of issues one we're sending data
out over the Internet so we need to make
sure that that data is protected from
being altered as someone is sending it
and also that someone can't read the
secret information that might be in that
data and we can do that using
cryptography we can use hashing to hash
the data that's in there and then say
whether it's been changed or not so we
can sign that hash in the same way that
Mike's talked about in other videos and
we can also use cryptography to
encrypt the data so they can't be
snooped on as it travels over the
internet so that's relatively
straightforward that gives us a private
part and we get the virtual part because
we're sending it over the internet over
a virtual link that we've created just
using a standard internet connection you
have to set up your corporate network so
that it knows that the packets going to
this particular IP address need to go
out over a virtual private network link
and so we can send it out over there and
also you need to make sure that the
machine the remote machine is sending
packets that are going to that machine
over the virtual network and so on
there's actually two ways you can get
the rowing machine to send packets you
can either just send the ones that are
going to that network there and let
everything else go out over the Internet
and that works fine you get a good
browsing speed but you might also be
using services on the internet that you
don't want people to know that if you're
working on you might be accessing
resources that could compromise your
business integrity and so on and so you
can also set it up and this is what
people use at home with they're using a
VPN to protect their connection so that
all your traffic is sent over the
virtual private network and then it
appears as if it's leaving from the
business network where it's coming out
of with their IP addresses even though
actually the machine is in a different
location and so the mr. data is can
encrypt it and send over that to the
destination and then sent on from there
as if you were connected to that Network
and so it's not proxying it's as
literally as if your machine is
connected to that network of course the
problem you have here is if you're
sending all your data out over the
virtual private network you need to make
sure that the virtual private network
traffic yourself isn't sent out over the
virtual private network otherwise it
wouldn't get there and the operator
Symphony's you take care of this because
the connection to the virtual private
network is created before you start
sending data over the virtual private
network so it can still track where it
needs to route that information over the
Internet the only other thing you need
is some way to authenticate who the
person using the network is and this is
usually done when you start up the
connection so where's are the normal
network connection these days we connect
to Wi-Fi you connect three
you're immediately connected to the
network there may be some access
controls there to say whether you can
actually use it in send things anywhere
but the technology immediately connects
you with a Virtual Private Network you
have to set that connection when you set
up that virtual connection with the
server they come the end and the client
of the remote end as configuring the
details so that they know where the IP
address is and where to send those
wrapped up packets back over the network
I understand what's being achieved there
but does this run into any problems at
all
obviously it's blockable you could see
the VPN traffic going over and you can
just sort of stop those packets being
sent and so on you shouldn't if the
encryption is good and actually setting
up for the encryption making this right
is quite difficult there's a lot of sort
of commercial home use VPNs or actually
if you're not careful it can be set up
so it's virtually not encrypted at all
the other thing to say from that point
of view is that it's still possible to
see what people are doing even if they
can't see actually the data they're
transferring I mean certain activities
that you might do everything internet
have specific patterns that data is
transferred in and so you can infer from
the way the packets over the VPN are
going what's actually happening there so
it's not true hidden things you could
still see some things for example the
difference between a sort of video
conferencing call like this and a
webpage you'd be able to say looks like
they're videoconferencing or looks like
they're sort of webpage you wouldn't
have full detail but you can sort of
infer that from the way the traffic is
sort of being transferred and things the
other thing is of course from more
practical point of view it will have
latency to you connection because you go
to send the packet to the VPN server and
then out to its destination
it'll have latency depending on how bad
the network is where you are but might
actually be faster because your business
has got a faster connection that might
be a more direct route than you going
directly follow and of course because
each packet has to be slightly smaller
to fit the extra headers in there then
you will run slightly slower than the
maximum speed you could transfer but
that's marginally less
there are swings around about direct
connection and so on
is always going to be faster but this
gives you a lot of peace of mind it
means you can have access as if you were
sitting on your corporate network if
this is our data path with our columns
by sharing bytes around the different
columns when we combine it with the
mixed column step which we'll do in a
minute you'll see that actually we're
mixing everything up so within just a
couple of rounds we can either make the
computer processor faster or we can have
multiple cores each working on part of
the problem at the same speed